[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce numéro de pas qu'on va
parler le long au lendemain du rejet de
la motion de censure de ce qui va se
passer maintenant avec Véronique Jérôme
bonjour Patrice bonjour vous êtes Polito
économiste et maître de conférence à
l'Université de Paris Saclay et
Jean-Charles Joly bonjour bonjour vous
êtes éditeur
on peut dire un mot de l'expatrier quand
même
colonel gendarmerie qui était 4 ans en
poste au Cameroun
et de flics
quand ils sont dans des salons ensemble
etc même ils sont plutôt bien
poste au Cameroun pendant 4 ans comme
attaché de sécurité intérieure et donc
il nous raconte dans l'expatrier une vie
passionnante d'un jeune corse qui est
objectif
enfin bref il arrive dans les années 60
à Marseille et là il rencontre Pasqua
qu'il prend sous son aile et puis ça va
un moment ça va se passer pas trop bien
il y a un moment où on va aborder même
le la tuerie d'Auriol donc on avance un
peu dans le temps et puis il est obligé
de s'exiler il va continuer à aller
vendre des armes il se retrouve au
Cameroun voilà et donc il y a deux
histoires il y a une histoire d'une
quarantaine d'années et puis une
histoire
et c'est tout à fait passionnant parce
que c'est historiquement passionnant et
puis sur ce qui se passe au Cameroun et
la réalité camerounaise c'est assez
angoissant il y avait déjà fait un
premier bouquin qui était un peu
angoissant aussi qui s'appelait waala là
il leur met une couche et je pense qu'il
est pas prêt de pouvoir retourner au
Cameroun il est autorisé ça le passe
quoi quand il était encore directeur de
Ricard exactement oui oui il invente ce
qu'on a appelé après le binzolking et
avec des tables ouverts pour les
étudiants pour les inciter à boire etc
maintenant qu'on évoque il évoque tout
ça c'est tout à fait passionnant
l'expatrier de Thierry Baudot
ça avec un grand plaisir
on est donc au lendemain du rejet de la
motion de censure traite de très peu de
voix de 9 voix
ce qui est ce qui veut dire que il y a
19 je crois que députés LR qui l'ont
voté on était au courant que la nuit
passée à la nouveauté que le
rassemblement national et nouveauté que
le petit groupe lyotte
alors qu'un groupe très particulier
c'est c'est Charles de Courson qui au
nom de ce groupe a défendu la motion de
censure mais la plupart des élus de ce
groupe sont des
ultramarins comme on dit enfin ils ont
aucun rapport entre réalité à part le
fait de constituer un groupe mais enfin
il y en a que deux dans leur groupe qui
n'ont pas voté la motion de censure
c'est quand même
dans l'histoire de la 5e République elle
a été votée une fois en 62
c'était sur le sujet de
l'élection président de la République au
suffrage universel et elle est passée de
voie de ne pas passer de peu de fois une
fois 68 je crois sous Pompidou encore
sur une loi sur la publicité à l'ORTF et
puis de trois voix à l'été de trois
voies en 92 avec beyrograd sur une loi
sur la sur la pacte sur la politique
agricole commune enfin bon mais face
cette voix c'est pas beaucoup la voix
pardon je trouve pas ça gênant du tout
parce que c'est quand même l'essence
même de la démocratie et de l'idée même
de la majorité une majorité quelle
qu'elle soit il y a une voie de plus ou
il y a pas de République a été voté une
voix voilà donc ça n'a rien de ce camp
c'est c'est tout à fait intéressant qui
ne voit j'imagine que Macron Isabelle
borne aurait préféré 52 ans mais bon le
peu importe sonne le résultat compte et
il faut respecter ce vote qui est
extrêmement démocratique puisque c'est
l'Assemblée nationale c'est la
représentation parlementaire qui décide
de ne pas mettre en le gouvernement donc
il faut respecter ça se comprend que les
opposants soient déçus mais bon je veux
dire c'est c'est le jeu et si à 9 mois
près il était passé là il serait tous en
train de de pousser des cris de joie en
disant c'est merveilleux donc voilà
donc la position du média finalement
c'est la position de celui qui est sur
le fil et qui va faire pencher d'un côté
ou de l'autre donc et on remarque aussi
la démocratie que tous les politiques
maintenant font des programmes pour
converger vers ce médian qui n'existe
pas vraiment mais qui a une réalité mais
qui n'a pas de réalité explicite et
essayer de trouver finalement ce qui va
faire consensus et on s'aperçoit que
finalement ici il y a quand même une
différence avec une un vote réel et
cette motion de censure parce que
finalement ça a mis un peu tout le monde
au pied du mur on n'est pas persuadé
enfin l'exécutif avec quand même laissé
entendre avait fait circuler l'idée
qu'il ne voulait absolument pas passer
au 49-3 parce qu'il voyait bien cet
aspect quand même un peu du voilà donc
il avait besoin il aurait préféré avoir
cette assise sentiment ce soutien et par
le vote et le vote aurait un vote de
cette loi au sens plein du terme aurait
peut-être mis un coup d'arrêt à une
partie je dis pas tout mais en tout cas
une partie des manifestations et des
revendications et une partie de
l'activité de syndicat parmi les plus je
dirais légitimistes la CFDT la CFDT
avait considéré que s'il y avait votes
ça voulait finalement dire quelque chose
et ça mettait un coup d'arrêt c'était
pas tout à fait la différence Laurent
Berger de la traiter de de déni de
démocratie
dans le monde pour demander à Macron de
ne pas promulguer la loi ce qui est
totalement illégal le président de la
République est obligé de promulguer une
loi qui a été votée
Carcassonne avec Chirac en laissant
promulguer la voix et en suspendant
finalement
donc une sus médiation c'est
respecterait pas le droit s'il ne
pourriez pas la la loi mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu ce débat un peu bizarre sur
je sais pas pourquoi le mauvaise
réputation du 49-3 alors que c'est un
vote
les partis politiques et les oppositions
en ce moment sont d'une malhonnêteté
incroyable c'est-à-dire qu'à refusé la
réalité c'est-à-dire que il y a rien de
de c'est compris dans la Constitution
c'est c'est clair et net c'est c'est
tout sauf anti-démocratique c'est
démocratique c'est la représentation
nationale qui vote ou qui votent pas
donc il y a pas de débat après on peut
on peut continuer à lutter contre la loi
mais mais c'est tout à fait démocratique
je veux dire c'est pas démocratique
ce qu'on ne voit pas c'est que derrière
le positionnement de certains et chez LR
le le la question c'est vraiment posée
et je crois quand même Pradier qui a
voté la motion de censure
n'hésitez pas persuadé de la voter enfin
dans le Figaro la veille il annonçait
qu'il la voterait pas si j'ai bien lu et
le lendemain
alors après la cohérence entre quelqu'un
qui était pour les 65 ans et qui refuse
des réalités des 64 ans mais il y a
aussi peut-être une autre question et
peut-être que le weekend a permis à
certains de se remettre au contact de la
réalité ceux qui sont retrouvés
retournés dans leur circonscription ont
eu quand même des échos qui n'étaient
pas exactement dans la teneur de ce
qu'il peut voir dans les ordres de la
République et dans les dans je dirais
porte fermée porte-close à l'Assemblée
nationale ça signifie quoi ça signifie
que si on en croit les sondages il y a
quand même encore une grande majorité de
Français qui ne comprennent pas cette
loi qui ne qui n'en veulent pas telle
qu'elle est établie peut-être qu'il
voudrait différente et qui ne veulent
pas de ces deux ans supplémentaires
parce qu'ils en ont fait un totem et on
aura mal expliqué peut-être les choses
et
finalement les députés ils sont à
l'écoute de ceux qui les ont fait roi
entre guillemets donc l'électorat à
partir du moment où il a cette
revendication que fait le député soit
une considère que il va voter contre la
motion de censure parce qu'il veut
protéger aussi son poste parce qu'il y
ait aussi un peu de ça si on considère
que il y a possibilité de dissolution
d'assemblée nationale tous ne sont pas
sûrs de retrouver aussi facilement leur
poste donc il y a un peu d'égo tropisme
dans cette histoire et il y a aussi et
il y a aussi les lecteurs qui pourraient
quand même considérer qu'il n'avait pas
été consultée préalablement c'est en
simple référendum pour être intéressant
parce que les lecteurs lorsqu'il veut il
y a pas voté pour la réforme c'est ce
qu'ils disent en tout cas
majoritairement voté pour Macron qui
voulait cotiser de la retraite à 65 ans
et on revient sur le vote
admettons la droite la droite a toujours
méditer pour cette retraite 150 donc on
a la paternité
après la campagne de Pécresse qui
voulait la retraite à 65 ans donc
de feu et intellectuel de la part de la
droite qui se s'aborde enfin la droite
n'existe plus c'est fini
on pourrait dire aussi que c'est très
bien joué de la part d'Emmanuel Macron
qui a capté cette réforme de la droite
qui a capté cette idée de droit c'est ce
qu'on appelle la triangulation c'est à
dire que pour mieux lutter contre un
opposant on absorbe une partie de son
programme pour absorber avec ses
électeurs donc on peut imaginer que
cette trans cette triangulation est à
l'origine de ce flou artistique il y a
autour de la réforme donc plus personne
ne sait exactement la nature c'est les
deux droites ou de gauche finalement
les gens qui sont concernés par la
réforme des retraites c'est-à-dire
qu'ils vont travailler plus longtemps ce
sont plutôt les des Français qui
n'aimaient pas Macron déjà et que ça ça
croit peut-être c'est vrai qu'il y a
aussi cette ce problème du rapport de
d'Emmanuel Macron au peuple français qui
est compliqué et qui est oui il y a une
sorte de parfois de web ça commence
les revendications dans les dans les
manifestations avec une certaine logique
qui était contre la réforme et
aujourd'hui il semble aussi que la base
va peut-être dépasser des syndicats et
qu'on a des manifestations qui ne sont
pas autorisées et il a tout est possible
et certains observateurs commencent à
dire rapporter qu'il y a des slogans qui
sont anti Macron et qui ne sont plus en
seulement en tirer forme donc là il va
cristalliser et son absence dans le
débat qui était tout à fait logique
à 13h alors c'est très intéressant
d'ailleurs parce que généralement quand
il ne location un peu officielle c'est
plutôt 20h
quand on veut dire des choses très
précises est-ce que 13h 13h c'est
d'ailleurs d'abord ça ça passe plus à la
province
et c'est important parce qu'on a vu la
mobilisation dans les dans les petite
ville contre la réforme de retraite et
puis généralement qu'on voit pas
annoncer des choses mieux au volantes le
président avait déjà fait ça avec à
l'époque Jean-Pierre Pernaut dans une
école assis sur une chaise des colliers
à 13h enfin bon voilà c'est
effectivement mais c'est assez curieux
parce que en tout cas moi j'aimerais
entendre le notre président de la
République être un peu solennel un peu
prendre un peu de la hauteur et dire
vraiment ce qu'on va faire alors que là
bon il va répondre à quelques questions
du travail
alors la première conséquence de ce vote
on avait il y a quand même une vingtaine
19 je crois députés LR qui ont voté la
mesure de censure comme vous le vous le
disiez alors que Éric Ciotti avait fait
des tribunes partout c'est exprimé pour
dire on soutient la loi alors que le
président du groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale hier enfin à l'Assemblée
nationale même dit on ne va pas voter la
motion de censure et mieux nous voir à
celle des extrêmes
ça veut dire quoi LR explosé mon volcan
c'est oui je sais que sciatique était en
train de chercher un nouveau siège pour
les républicains ils vont vendre celui
qu'ils ont voulu
acheter un studio enfin je veux dire ça
devient
téléphonique
ça devient un ridicule enfin je veux
dire la moitié de la droite va aller
rejoindre Marine Le Pen l'autre moitié
va rejoindre Macron et l'explosion dont
on parlait depuis longtemps elle est en
train de se produire voilà donc il y a
plus de parti socialistes il y a plus de
parties à droite voilà maintenant on va
avec un parti où c'est agrégeron
peut-être
encore que on sait pas mais Édouard
Philippe et puis depuis quelques
personne satellite autour de d'un parti
plus ou moins préconise et puis après
l'extrême droite est l'extrême gauche
voilà c'est mais
des divisions pour les ambitions
à la présidentielle
3 % mais c'est pas par contre pour la
suivante celle-ci mais la suivante
je pense que il y aura toujours une
droite en France au sens je dirais
Sciences Po du terme il semblerait quand
même assez compliqué d'imaginer voilà
mais après le problème c'est qu'il faut
il faut un leader il faut quelqu'un de
charismatique qui incarne et là pour
l'instant il y a absence de
qui attend mais à force d'attendre
on voit pas qui va pouvoir réunir
puisqu'il y a plus personne quoi donc
dans les dans les prés proposer il y
avait ok il y a Xavier Bertrand et puis
il y a David Linard dont on sait pas
très bien si il a envie de faire quelque
chose parce que apparemment il est sur
un créneau où il a des mères le
président de France
mais non c'est vrai que il attend mais à
un moment
quel trouble il va pouvoir lire quand on
va alors dire que c'est vrai qu'il y a
ce
tout un tas de gens qui sont persuadés
que l'élection présidentielle 2027 se
jouera entre la droite et l'extrême
droite mais bon pour être présente la
droite il faut avoir quand même des
soutiens et là on voit mal quels sont
les outils de vous qui est entre la
gauche et l'extrême droite
j'allais dire entre les lycéens parce
que quand on voit la photo que vous nous
montrez derrière si c'est ça si c'est
devenu ça l'Assemblée nationale bon on a
l'impression d'une assemblée dans un
truc d'étudiants quoi ces gens sont
députés c'est la représentation
nationale sont là des panneaux des trucs
ils injurent la première ministre ils
ont duré
tout le monde c'est celui qui sait pas
lire j'imagine mais c'est un des
problèmes d'ailleurs
de l'état de la politique française
c'est-à-dire que il y a en effet une
majorité très relative qui soutient
Emmanuel Macron et en face il y a des
oppositions qui sont incapables de
s'entendre c'est ça aussi pour l'homme
de la de la motion de censure qui est
généralement quand on fait une notion de
censure on espère pouvoir
présenter une alternance au pouvoir en
place alors là il y a pas d'alternance
possible
heureusement qu'ils arrivent pas à
s'unir mais en même temps bon entre le
Mélenchon de Marine Le Pen
économiquement il pourrait tout à fait
s'unir vu qu'ils sont à peu près le même
programme mais sinon après il y a quand
même assez peu de choses qui peuvent
réunir tous ces gens-là donc
effectivement c'est c'est des des
petites tâches comme ça dans l'assemblée
de de gens qui se conduisent quand même
enfin il y a un déni de démocratie et ce
qui me fait peur c'est que
un discours anti-démocratique consiste
dès qu'un vote ne plaît pas à quelqu'un
de dire bah c'est pas démocratique bah
non c'est si bien sûr que c'est
démocratique si le vote aussi
syndicats disent on n'a pas été entendu
Messi
mais quand on voit quand on voit
Mélenchon hier enfin après le qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont visiteurs
dans son grand manteau de cuir enfin
avec des postures quasiment
mussolinienne en train de dire
nous nous allons maintenant faire parler
la rue enfin de me dire qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce discours
inadmissible parce qu'il s'adresse en
plus à une une clientèle qui est souvent
assez jeune très malléable et on voit le
le délire que ça peut apporter
responsable parce qu'on voit ça deuxième
leçon qu'on peut tirer de ce côté de la
potion de censure c'est quand même la
fin de ce qu'on appelle total de ce
qu'on appelait le Front républicain on
savait que la nups mince malgré ses
voies à celle du rassemblement national
mais là une partie importante de députés
LR même aussi leur voix à celle du
rassemblement national je pense que
Chirac doit se retourner dans sa tombe
que
Sarkozy demande dans quel monde divine
parce que ça a été toujours une
frontière contre franchise pas on se
souvient même des quatre des quatre
cavaliers qui sont avec les cavaliers de
l'Apocalypse mais des ministres qui de
droite qui avait dit il vaut mieux
perdre une élection que son âme bon bah
là
ouais c'est Michel Noir Carignon
Léotard et je ne sais plus qui était
quatrième mais peut-être enfin bref mais
enfin c'est effectivement c'est ça il a
dit il a sauté et là on entend pas une
seule personne à gauche dire bah oui
c'est quand même curieux on vote avec
l'extrême droite
c'est plus significatif encore parce
qu'il y avait quand même toujours eu
cette cette barrière oui vous déjà enfin
par Chirac dès le début quoi c'est une
barrière qui les a aussi plombées très
longtemps parce que le Parti Social fait
tomber la barrière avec le Parti
communiste ça les a porté au pouvoir à
un moment donc de se séparer à ce qu'on
a et se couper d'une partie est-ce que
c'est et puis il y a des électeurs
voilà très bien dans un salon etc on dit
ok on ferait pas ensemble mais peut-être
que c'est indispensable électoralement
par moment parce que comme vous le dites
justement les électeurs qui dit bah oui
mais pourquoi sur ce sujet là pourquoi
pas qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est cette
propre et puis voilà on peut pas après
il y a toujours le problème de la copie
d'original c'est-à-dire que si on fait
la même chose que les autres mais on
aura peut-être un fond républicains
ils sont venus dans la circonscription
et et c'est en écoutant leurs électeurs
qu'ils ont euh
et on aura peut-être un front en
républicain un peu particulier quand on
entend comment le RN qui avait
finalement fait mais là au grand jour en
disant où elle est qui accepterait de
voter la motion qu'il ne mettrait pas si
dissolution il y a de candidats en face
des LR en question si il y avait
possibilité de triangulaire donc c'est
une façon pour eux de rentrer dans le
jeu dont ils ont largement profité par
le passé et d'essayer de de monter comme
ça des alliances enfin de présupposer
alliance et d'essayer de faire
reconnaître cette cette
possible coopération entre le yadr et le
RN et ça c'est c'est un point qu'il va
falloir quand même trancher et résoudre
parce que les choses sont pas claires
le rassemblement national on parle de
faire sauter la digue enfin c'est
sadique qui a sauté depuis
l'élection la dernière élection ils ont
à mon sens décroché leur brevet des
responsabilités il se conduit il se
conduisent très bien l'assemblée quand
on voit la nuit pêche et le rationnaire
mais bon ben je suis pas du tout en
train de dire vivre le rassemblement
mais mais franchement on s'attendait pas
à ça quoi je veux dire que ce soit c'est
quasiment des attitudes de factueux d'un
côté à l'extrême gauche
ils sont posés eux qui faisaient
toujours peur etc donne une image deux
extrêmement rassurant et voilà c'est
important la communication non verbales
est importante il y a quand même des
règles non dites à l'Assemblée où on ne
vient pas en jean en basket enfin on ne
vient pas si la preuve il y en a on
envoie quand on voit les couleurs
généralement c'est quand même un peu
plus un peu plus classique et l'autre
chose c'est que le rassemblement
national j'entendais l'interview de
l'interview ce matin de de Marine Le Pen
sur Europe 1 qui annonce enfin je ne
sais pas si celle qui l'a annoncé mais
il y a une véritable école qui est mise
en place par un ancien sondeur Jérôme
sanparis pour pas le citer et pour faire
en sorte que les candidats du RL
maintenant est de quoi répondre et une
formation ne soit plus simplement comme
ça un peu les gens pris au hasard et
donc une vraie volonté peut-être de
ce professionnaliser et d'apparaître
comme un parti potentiellement
pour devenir la partie du gouvernement
un jour parce qu'on peut pas
d'ailleurs après il va falloir qu'il
trouve des alliés pour européens pour
comme elle l'a fait en Italie pour
entrer dans les gouvernements
troisième conséquence c'est que la loi
est votée donc principe là pour
l'instant c'est fait après il faut
qu'elle soit
d'applications il y a le conseiller le
passage de constitutionnel enfin la loi
va principe doit s'appliquer quoi
quelques articles qui pourraient être
rejetés comme l'article 2 sur la le
l'aspect senioration l'index le Seigneur
parce que ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'aspect financier c'est juste un index
et en même temps c'est un peu de la
poudre aux yeux ça n'a aucune mesure qui
sera qu'une mesure comme ça pour dire
qu'on a mis une mesure et qui n'aura pas
d'efficacité demander aux entreprises de
dire si elles ont des seniors dans leur
dans leur dans leur rang et simplement
de le dire et de s'est passé ces 22
États sinon justement de ne pas les
taxer de ne rien faire la carotte mais
il y a pas de bâton voilà donc ça ne
fera rien au cas des seniors et ça ne
fera rien à des situations donc ça ça
risque de ne pas être retenu mais la loi
restera elle sera peut-être des tricotée
c'est là aussi oui on va voir après ce
qui va se passer c'est vrai qu'elle est
mobilisation syndicale et populaire
il y a des mais qui sont pas enfin dans
le dernier moment probablement que dans
les manifestations jeudi il y aura il y
aura du monde mais jusqu'à présent
c'était quand même assez minoritaire ces
manifestations contrairement à ce que
disent la plupart des médias
depuis deux jours
50 millions de d'électeurs
il y avait 500 personnes alors bon après
c'est les capacités nuisances
c'est le pouvoir de nuisances de du
pourrissement parce qu'on est dans une
situation où l'inflation pèse lourdement
sur les décisions et tous ceux qui vont
manifester pour ceux qui ont un job en
tout cas c'est une journée c'est
peut-être parfois une journée de salaire
en moi parfois c'est des heures en moins
mais ça peut être une journée de salaire
en moins il y a déjà eu je crois je sais
pas 7 cette manifestation semble-t-il
donc ceux qui veulent être de façon
assidue à ces manifestations comment ça
faire les comptes et se disent ben
finalement ça ne rapporte rien ça me
coûte donc un vrai coup d'opportunité il
y a un vrai arbitrage à faire et donc il
a peut-être que ils vont revoir
le blocage des raffineries tout ça la
chose la plus populaire qui qui soit
vous avez tout à fait raison mais c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il y a eu une grande
manif le samedi parce que parce que
samedi c'est gratuit
et les familles peuvent venir avec les
poussettes parce qu'il y a aussi cette
expérience
un dernier mot parce qu'il
une proposition de de
Manuel Valls qui me paraît assez
intelligente qui est de dire on va pas
pouvoir continuer enfin le pouvoir va
pas pouvoir continuer comme ça à trouver
des majorités au cas par cas avec en
effet des groupes comme LR qui ne sont
pas fiables donc il faut constituer une
majorité et c'est vrai que il y a
peut-être cette possibilité de
constituer une majorité avec les LR
fiable qui reste peut-être quelque chose
que démocrate qui en ont marre d'être
sur la coupe de Mélenchon je ne sais pas
mais ça serait peut-être pas
idiot
ce serait tout à fait tout à fait sensé
ça fait intelligent on aurait
l'impression que que la France peut
repartir que la France effectivement
vraiment dirigée qu'on peut améliorer
les choses etc sur sur des grands sujets
on peut pas peut-être dire des que des
sujets régaliens mais c'est vrai que
l'armement la défense l'armement la
justice le
le service public
donc tout ça c'est la sécurité
extrêmement important et effectivement
il y aura une alliance en gros des
modérée qui ne se qui ne considère pas
l'élection de Marine Le Pen en 2027
comme une fatalité en gros c'est ça
voilà
qui se disent pas tous les matins oui
c'est inéluctable genre on a qu'à on a
qu'à se préparer un mobile
cohabitation sans la dissolution en fait
oui peut-être avec le Premier ministre
de droite pourquoi pas enfin
c'est en tout cas il va falloir faire
quelque chose mais il faudrait voir à
qui ça profite le plus c'est ce que
c'est au pays où à ses intérêts
politiciens qui vont former l'Union il
faudrait quand même vérifier que ça
profite bien au pays et pas des
ambitions de carrière et un petit peu
toujours angoissant c'est que le
président Macron a enfin réussi à
dynamiter la droite et la gauche mais il
a au-delà de ça il a aussi dynamité j'ai
l'impression le le la relève parce que
on ne voit pas d'homme politique
et ça ça me fait peur donc et bon on
s'arrête là parce que on aura l'occasion
d'en parler évidemment de respect qui
vient merci beaucoup Véronique Jérôme
merci beaucoup de Johnny à bientôt et à
très vite
[Musique]